So after having everything set up, we now need to go to our game mode and after our
countdown timer, if we play the game right now, what's going to happen is it's going
to count to negative after it goes to zero.
So we need to put in what happens when we reach zero and that is call our game
over functionality that we just set up.
So again, to do this, what we're going to do is we're going to come down to our
vehicles, not our vehicles, I apologize, our vehicle template, our blueprints, and then
our vehicle advanced game mode.
And here we go.
So basically we need to finish off what happens after this little
bit of code becomes true.
And what we're going to do first, just need to make my
notes a little bit larger here.
So what we need to do first is we are going to pull off the true because
when it is less than zero, we want this to happen.
We are going to go remove from, we might need to disable context sensitivity.
There we go.
And that does it.
So we want this widget removed from parent.
Again, if you do not see that disabled context sensitive, and we will get that
option and we want our HUD ref.
So we're going to grab this right here and plug it right over there.
Remember, we got this from when we draw the HUD up here, we
promoted this to a variable.
So this is the HUD that we want to remove.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to pull off of this
and we're going to set no mouse.
And again, if you have context sensitivity enabled, this will not show up.
So make sure you have this check mark box up here turned off.
We want this set show mouse cursor, and we want to set that true.
And we do need to give this a target because while this node will work, the
target is basically, okay, I know you want to set this value to true.
Who do you want to give it to?
And we want to set that on our get player controller, and I'm going to
enable context sensitivity just to make sure that I get the right player controller.
There we go.
We're going to plug this in like, so next, what we're going to do is we're
going to pull off of this set here, and we're going to go set input mode, and
we're going to set input mode to UI only, and this is going to ensure that
we just are able to interact with the UI and we don't interact with the game
in any particular way, this might not be needed on such a small project, but
this is just good practice as your project starts to grow in complexity,
having things like this will really start to help out next, what we're
going to do is we are going to take the output from our player controller,
because again, this set input node needs to know what player we're
going to be restricting to, and we want to do that to our player controller.
So there we go.
And we will move that over like, so then what we want to do is as we did
up before we want to create a widget.
So we are going to pull off of this create widget and what
widget do we want to create?
Well, we want our WB game over.
And then what we're going to do is in this particular case, we are not going
to make a return value for this or promote this return to a variable.
We are just going to pull directly off of this and go add to view, add to
viewport, and we are going to plug that in like so now, the reason we're not
promoting that to a variable is that this particular screen, unlike the UI,
this is going to be a one off screen.
So we always know this is going to come up if we ever wanted to access
the UI or get a reference to it so that we can turn it on or turn
it off because it's kind of a global screen, that would make sense.
But since this happens in a very specific location at a very specific
time, we don't need to do any of that.
So let's just look at this blueprint one more time.
So off of our branch here, we remove parent, we remove again,
our UI that we currently have.
We set our mouse cursor so that we can interact with the UI widget.
We make sure that our input is set to UI mode only so that we only are
working within the UI.
We then create our game over menu and then we add that to the viewport.
So let's compile and save.
So what should be happening now is when I press play, we should
after this counts down, there we go and then click restart
and we should be back in the project.
Fantastic.
Now, just again, to recap, because the important part of this is removing
our widget and then re-adding a new widget.
So this is just a close up of the code that we just built and tested.
So just have a look here.
If yours is not working, this just gives you a little bit
of a closer view of that.
So we are almost done.
The next thing that we need to do is we need to create a menu.
So generally when you play a project, there is a start menu that allows
you to start or exit or go to options or things like that.
So we're going to do that by first creating an empty level
that we call start map.
And let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're just going to do file, new level, empty level, select create.
I'm going to go ahead and save my stuff that's checked out.
And then we are going to save this as and just make sure,
there we go, start map.
OK, then what we're going to do with that start map saved is we are going
to go to our game projects settings and we are going to set the editor
start map and the game default map to this start map or start menu.
What this is going to do is ensure that whenever this project is loaded,
the level that we want people to either start from when they're playing it
or start from when they're editing it to be this particular map.
So let's do that now by coming over here,
going to edit project settings, project settings was off screen.
So let me pull this back over for everybody to see.
And then we're going to go to maps and modes.
And we can see here vehicle game examples, the editor start.
But we don't want that.
We want start map and start map.
Now, what we're going to do is create another widget blueprint
and build that widget blueprint with some text and a start button.
So let's go ahead and create that now.
So we're going to close this and we're going to go to our content
browser, user interface, widget, blueprints, user widget.
We're going to call this one WB underscore start underscore.
Got a little messed up there.
So let's just redo that.
Right.
And then we're going to double click on this to open it up.
And again, canvas.
So we'll add a canvas panel to go.
And then there's an image.
We're going to add an image and then we're going to add a button.
And then we're going to add some text to that button.
So with our image, let's grab that.
Take our anchor that this oops and I forgot.
So one of the things if you forget to do that, hit control.
We can just go back up here and do that one more time.
And it will set that so that we get it going all the way across.
We're going to set this maybe to like
bluish color and a value down there we go.
OK, then let's take our button here and I'm going to hold down again,
control and center that one.
And oh, we do need another piece of text.
So let's just drag that on there.
We're going to grab this and let's just center to find it right there.
And with our text up here, we're going to go size to content.
And then I'm going to set its alignment to point five.
Bye. I'll make point five and now just leave it at zero.
Then I'm going to bring this down and the Y position about 256.
That looks about good.
All right. We're going to set this up to I think I use 96 in the other menu.
I think that looked pretty good.
Give it a spacing or an outline of two.
And this is going to say vehicle game.
There we go.
And then again, here, what we're going to do is we're going to grab this button.
We're going to say size to content
so that it actually matches the size of whatever text we have in there.
We're going to set its alignment to point five
because this will center it up in that box for us nicely.
And then we're going to grab this text and we're going to change it to say 64.
There we go. We're also going to give it an outline of one
and maybe two would actually be probably a little bit better.
Yep. And then we are going to start.
So like we did with our last example,
we're going to take this start button and do an on click.
And then we're going to set up the following little bit of code.
So basically when we press this button, we are going to load our vehicle demo map.
So let's do that right now.
We are going to grab our start button start button right there.
We're going to come down in the details panel
and unclicked, so we're going to hit the unclicked.
And then what we're going to do is get player controller.
Right. Get our player controller and then pull off of our unclicked set show.
And then I'm going to uncheck that.
So there's my set show mouse cursor.
We're going to set that to true.
And then we're going to take the return value and plug that right here.
Next, we are going to pull off of this set
and we're going to go set input mode
and we're going to say set input mode game only.
And as before, we need this return value to go into our player controller.
And last but not least, we're going to pull off of this one
and go open level and open level by name.
And I just want to make sure we have ours called.
We're going to go to vehicles, not vehicles. I'm sorry.
It is under maps and vehicle example.
So what you can do just to double check is I'm going to hit F2
and then just copy that name right to my clipboard and then control V.
All right. So compile and save that so we can close this now,
because the next thing we're going to do is we're going to come up here
to our level blueprint and then inside of our level blueprint,
we are going to basically recreate the code that we did to make this
menu show up in the various previous examples.
We are going to on event begin play, create our widget,
add it to the viewport, enable our mouse cursor
and then set our input mode to UI only.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So again, back inside of the editor, we're to come up to our level blueprint.
There we go. I'm going to maximize this now.
I can remove this event tick because it's not needed
and we can always add it after the fact if we need it later on.
What we're going to do off of this event begin play is left click and drag
and we want our create widget.
And then from our create widget,
what we're going to do is we're going to look for our WB start menu.
Then we're going to pull off of our executive pen
and add to view and add to viewport.
So there we go.
And then again, take our return value and add it here.
Again, we're not promoting this return value
because this is going to be a unique operation, unique to this scene
where we're never really going to have to reference this again.
Then once we're done with that, we're going to pull off of our
add to viewport and look for set show mouse.
And we might need to disable context
sensitivity and boom set show mouse cursor.
Now, as with before, we need to enable that because we want to show that
and we are going to need to get our player controller.
So get player all over the place of spelling today.
I'm going to enable my context sensitive.
So there we go.
Underneath game is the one that I want get player controller.
We're going to take the return value
and plug that into our self here of our set show mouse cursor.
So now we'll be able to see our mouse cursor.
And then last but not least, we want set input
and we want set input mode UI only.
And then we want to take our player controller
and plug that in there.
So what should happen?
And we will test this in just a second.
Trying to move this node down, it's giving me trouble.
There we go.
So compile and save.
So let's go ahead and press play and start.
And what should happen now as our time runs out
and we should be able to restart.
There we go.
So let's also just test real quick as we drive our really fancy car around.
Make sure I can get some.
Oh, didn't do it fast enough.
So let's try it one more time this time.
All right.
Well, that gave me some some time.
I got it just in the nick of time.
Let's just wait here for a second.
See what's going on.
There we go. Look at that game over.
Final score five restart.
So one of the things that we could do and further approve upon this
is that we can also add maybe another button here
so that we don't have just restart.
We have restart and maybe main menu.
And then from our main menu, one of the things that we could do
is if we come here, let's just go back to our content real quick
and we'll look at our start main menu.
There is I'm just going to come to the graph.
If we do quit, there is a quick game here.
So we could actually wire up a quick button that when we press it,
it will quit our our game.
And the cool thing about this quick game is that it will exit
the game based on the preference of the platform.
So this is really cool because you can set this up and when you quit it,
it will quit the game by closing it on PC.
But if you're playing it on Android,
it would suspend the app, not actually shut the app down.
So very, very cool stuff there.